Seamans owes a lot of its success to its
broad range of divisions and the variety
of products it offers it's a world
leader in medical technology for example
as a maker of computer tomography
scanners or hearing aids it makes wind
turbines along with all kinds of other
turbine generators and even entire power
stations futuristic Siemens trains carry
passengers around the world and its
technology regulates manufacturing
systems and building amenities today the
Siemens Group employs around 350,000
people worldwide but it hasn't all been
sunshine ten years ago corruption cast a
cloud over the company under the
leadership of Heine - PETA Siemens
pleaded guilty to corruption on a vast
scale and had to pay some 1 and a half
billion euros to settle the graft
charges it took a major management
shakeup to turn the company around now
170 years after its founding Siemens
still remains one of Europe's biggest
engineering companies and now it's
entering into the age of industry 4.0
Siemens aims to be a data navigator in
tomorrow's digital world providing
technology which analyzes systems and
utilizes their information it's a
rapidly expanding sector in modern
factories machines and even product
components communicate with each other
that requires systems management
technology and transportation is also on
the threshold of a new era cars and
traffic signals transmit data which can
be used to direct traffic flows these
systems are also vital for self-driving
vehicles it's a future Siemens doesn't
want to miss out on